♪ ♪
GLAWSHES BREAKING NEWS A SERIAL
KILLER IS BEHIND BARS AFTER
WEEKS ON EDGE THE CITY OF
STOCKTON, CALIFORNIA CAN REST
EASILY TONIGHT.
POLICE HAVE ARRESTED THE MAN
THEY BELIEVE IS RESPONSIBLING
FOR FIVE DEATHS IN THE CITY.
AND POSSIBLY ANOTHER IN OAKLAND
BELIEVED THAT THEY CAUGHT HIM
JUST AS HE WAS ABOUT TO TRY TO
TAKE AT LIFE.
THES MAYOR OF STOCKTON KEVIN
JOINED US LIVE IN THICK OF THE
INVESTIGATION HE JOINS US ONCE
AGAIN WITH THIS BREAKING UPDATE.
MAYOR, WE'VE BEEN PRAYING FOR
YOU GUYS OUR AUDIENCE HAS AH AS
ALWAYS AND YOU'VE GOT BIG NEWS
FOR US TONIGHT.
YOU REPORTED DURING PRESS
DHARCHES HE WAS ABOUT TO TAKE
SOMEONE'S LIVES AND ABLE TO
REACH HIM BECAUSE OF THE TIPS
THAT CAME IN AS WELL AS
SURVEILLANCE THAT YOU WERE